had a couple of bangers man who's the
big boss this guy you okay Anthony
DeVito over here yeah
what's your last name what Italian do
you have more Greek
oh my God yo you got so much greasy
Italian Vibe coming off of you I've
never seen so many stereotypical
Italians running a tech business in my
life what do you mean why because the
tech business should look like this yeah
Mr Ragusa thanks for inviting your
Indian staff
hey he can't they're in India
getting paid 30 rupees for every [__]
how are they working I'm gonna tell you
right now this seems this this seems
like such a front yeah I've ever seen a
business yeah
everybody's got the Saint Anthony
Medallion underneath their shirt it's
ridiculous yeah yeah check I get it yeah
if someone hacks you guys you just go
break their legs physically
is that what happened we'll [__]
Trace their IP and [__] you just got
Ragusa
I've never met such a weird front
is so funny God damn I knew that was
your last name I never heard that last
name of your life but that [__] is yours
can I help you with your software the
[__] out of here
and even the mafia didn't want this guy
isn't that crazy his name is Mike Ragusa
that's such a Mafia Ass name like
[__] why don't you run our
Google search
[Music]
I love this girl yeah yeah yeah yeah
this girl is great yeah that's her boss
she don't like you that's why she
laughing so much she's been waiting for
somebody to [__] on you for eight years
every man comes in a company makes more
money than her cause you're too [__]
misogynistic Italian to pay her equally
and this is her payback finally she gets
to laugh at you look she's like please
don't just be like please I'm gonna get
fired that's already underpays you
anyway don't ask this guy how much he
makes he's gonna blow your [__] mind
oh
my God yes
we got him
that's amazing you're gonna go apply for
other jobs she's definitely on the phone
going ragusa's on to me
what did your dad do
I don't ask that question come on girl I
just want to know he worked in garbage
yeah the garbage he worked in cement
Jimmy Hoffa is under eight feet of it
right now pumped her a goose attack
where we'll leave every virus at the
bottom of the East River
your dad was a federal agent who was
your dad Giuliani
I bet it was a [__]
we go back to questions after this
you've got a question everyone shut up
if you know what's good for you oh shut
the [__] up first of all he has a
question he has a question
no I don't think so has there ever been
one of you no no no why are you gonna
take care of him
okay I'll give you a list yeah why not
tonight Jerry Seinfeld sleeps with the
fishes
foreign
[Music]